chaque jour ils arrivent ici par
dizaines tous ont quitté le dombass la
majorité de ces réfugiés sont des femmes
des enfants et des personnes âgées dans
ce centre d'accueil de dnipro ils
viennent chercher un peu des deux vous
voyez là vous avez des produits
d'hygiène d'accord mais est-ce que vous
avez des draps pour dormir aussi s'il
vous plaît oui oui des volontaires vont
vous en apporter dans l'urgence les
bénévoles offrent des produits de
première nécessité de la nourriture des
vêtements ou encore des jouets pour les
enfants ici les exilés de la guerre
trouve de quoi tenir quelques jours
parmi les nouveaux arrivants ce couple
originaire de mahmoud dans le donbass
leur bébé est âgé d'à peine un mois nous
avons décidé de fuir car c'était trop
dangereux nous avons tout laissé
derrière me ce couplage est aussi a dû
fuir dans l'urgence en dehors de cette
aide humanitaire
ils n'ont plus rien
que pour nous emporter avec nous
nous sommes si vieux et je marche avec
une canne
43 mille réfugiés ont déjà transité par
ce centre d'accueil selon l'onu plus de
12 millions d'ukrainiens ont dû quitter
leurs foyers depuis le début de la
guerre